I turn my camera on I cut my fingers on
the
way okay so this is a since this is a
JavaScript conference we decided to use
our create our slides in JavaScript uh
yeah so I'm Dexter and this is Lawrence
and we'll be taking you through this
slides um so let's say you've created a
spanking new application uh and then the
internet Smiles on you and then it
becomes super popular so suddenly all
all the people around the world want to
use it and then um you know some people
might want to abuse it for all sorts of
random reasons like crash your server
steal your data stuff like that so yeah
you must be wondering how to you solve
this so um I'll be taking you through
security um and then Lawrence will be
taking you through template
specialization and um performance okay
so um here are some quick tips to help
get your application secure um so as
most of you know uh Express and not GS
they don't come with any security
features at all it's just Bare Bones and
yeah it's just simple so my first tip
for you is to get you guys to establish
good security defaults um so there are
some libraries out there that will help
you do this um you can use lka which is
part of uh PayPal's CJs or you can new
helmet uh which willu has mentioned
earlier uh so I won't be going too much
into detail uh on all these all all
these different types of texts um but
for yeah because W has already mentioned
it earlier so um for those of you
familiar with uh Express middleware um
you can it's just stuff that you add on
to every request and response so um you
can just use app.use and include all
these six lines and then you will kind
of you'll be set to create uh to get
your application secure so so csrf is
just yeah your usual uh con request fory
somebody steals your cookie and makes a
malicious request on your behalf uh and
then CSP is content security policy uh
content security policy is just like a
white list uh it allows you to specify
sites that you'll allow your application
to access without uh yeah without any
problems so um yeah you can you can use
it to apply to your images fonts scripts
stuff like that yeah and x-frame x-frame
just prevent helps you to prevent click
jacking attacks so it just basically
prevents you from loading uh prevents
anyone from loading your site in the IE
uh pgp is just some old IE stuff it
stands for platform for privacy
preferences project uh and then HSS is
um https strict Transport Security it
just forces your application to use um
https uh communication only yeah so
you'll prevent any HP communication and
xss protection you just uh help helps
you to uh prevent prevent your browser
from any XX attacks okay uh then helmet
has pretty similar functions uh except
for maybe P2P uh you can you can use
power by um yeah so you can Power by
just hides your uh what what what your
web application is powered by you can
even spoof them say it's powered by PHP
when it's actually not
JS yep so all these security defaults
can get you about 80% of the way there
um and then here's some other tips that
will help you get nearer to
100% so uh my next tip was know what you
require uh most of the time when we use
dependencies we don't really know uh we
don't really look into what the code uh
what what they wrote in their dependency
and to see what exactly they're doing so
um yeah you know not GS is running on uh
your server site so potentially people
could do all sorts of crazy stuff you
know they can just sniff your data they
can crash your server anytime they want
to stuff like that I mean it's pretty
unrealistic but yeah yeah it's possible
so don't let them do that such uh do
that kind of stuff um a more realistic
reason uh for knowing what you require
is because eval is evil um sometimes
eval can be used misused and um you know
you you don't want your dependency to be
exposing a vulnerability for you uh so
make sure if your if your dependency is
using eval make sure they they don't let
any user input to get in there or any
kind of um potentially dangerous
dangerous input to get into your eil
statement
uh yeah if you're not sure about eval at
all just avoid dependencies that use
eval yeah you can just use a control F
and then find if it uses eval anywhere
in your
dependency yep so uh my next STP is to
update your dependencies I know this is
a chore uh yeah but and I sound like I'm
nagging
but you got to update your dependencies
because you know there are known
security vulnerabilities out there uh
you don't want to be a victim of it you
don't want to push such vulnerable code
to production so yeah just update update
your
dependencies um there are some packages
you can use um there's gr NSP package
which is created by the folks at note
security project so um you can use this
uh include it as part of your CI to help
you scan for vulnerabilities what it
what it does it basically just um you
you run it in your grand task and then
you can see what um module is um
vulnerable uh the installed version that
you have that is vulnerable when it's
patched uh which if any that's a vulner
vulnerable dependency that it's the the
package is using and a URL that you can
check uh to see uh details about the
vulnerability okay so um retire JS is
another module that you can use uh you
can also check help you check for uh
outdated dependencies uh retired GS can
be run using couple of ways um yeah you
I I I would use the the ground module
and then include in my CI as well so as
you can see in the print the output put
uh yeah it's pretty similar it just it
shows you the vulnerability and your
module okay so uh my last tip is to make
sure that you guys Escape everything uh
you know because xss sucks uh it's
everywhere uh we it's all yeah we all we
all hate it um so what I mean by Escape
is uh over there you can above you can
see uh unescaped piece of string uh in
that string if if that string is
rendered into your browser will just run
as a script uh as you can see in the
output that's like in Chrome or
something so that will run the the the
cookie th. Js from I will steal your
cookie.com and then you will steal your
cookie and then yeah you're you're
you're kind of vulnerable so when you're
escaping content uh you're just
basically HTML encoding your stuff uh in
the bottom you can see um yeah all the
ENT stuff and then when it outputs uh
you just output as a string and then
basically if you just you just prevented
a cross side uh cross side yeah cross
side
attack okay so uh yeah here's a real
life example of xss attack so yeah the
pmo site was some government website was
kind of hacked and then this this whole
long URL was in uh like the the the link
the link that you could click and then
um the out but basically it's already
escaped so when it outputs it just
outputs say harmless
HTML
yeah so I'm I mean so far the examples
we've been talking about uh they are
just all for outgoing data like stuff
that you render to your browser and
stuff um please Escape stuff that comes
into your application as well because uh
when this this this this uh xss attack
it uh get stored in your database uh
when you each time you retrieve it it
get uh it runs again and then it's it's
even worse it's it's a persistent or St
accesss attack which is yeah bad so um
one way you can do escaping is um uh you
can just use what I've uh written in
this function uh it's just play no
JavaScript you can just use the browser
HTML encoder to help you do it there are
other ways uh maybe you can use jQuery
some jQuery stuff or maybe you can use
like um reject to do it uh but yeah this
is just one example so yep just to recap
um have some good uh good security
defaults um you can use loose SC or
helmet um know what you require make
sure they're not exposing application
with any uh vulnerable dependencies um
uh yeah scan and update your
dependencies with Grant NSP package and
retire. GS and lastly Escape everything
incoming and outgoing of your
application okay so yeah I'll be talking
about template specialization so quick
show of hand who here knows what
template specialization is
anyone okay so I have to go on with my
to so the thing is uh earlier tan
actually talked about how you do
localization using using his uh L10 NS
library and localization is actually
done on a lot of international site you
see out there which is why we talk we
said is how you prepare for skill
because you want to prepare for a case
where you have visitors from all over
the world but uh so what we realized at
PayPal is that localization is not just
about the language the way we display
content matters a lot and uh so quick
show of hand who here runs who here
comes from
MNC anyone okay so when you build your
site do you localize based on country
like do you localize the layout or do
you just localize the content or how do
you do
it localize the content anyone else from
MNC here no one all startup
crop okay so for the startups here who
here localizes
stuff okay so I see Zim there right so
how do you guys localize your content
like do you localize content or do you
localize the pages or what do you do for
localization Str only the strings so
basically the content only so you use
l10s so what we realize at paper is that
the way the behavior of consumers in
different countries varies a lot so what
works in one country might not work for
another so I'll just show a couple of
examples of
that so what we have here is Google's I
mean you guys know this Google's page is
quite straight forward uh there are
three columns and there is it all goes
from the top to bottom and it's really C
right each column you go from top to
bottom top to bottom top to bottom and
this is what we in Singapore and in most
of the western parts of the world we are
used to and this is the Chinese side uh
basically what you have here is you
have four column uh so in this row you
have four columns in this row you have
two columns in this row have three
columns and you have another column here
and this is it looks like five but it's
actually Four columns so it's quite
clutter so uh I remember hearing this
story before about some guys who
actually went to do user studies in
China and what they actually found out
was that because there are some internet
connections in China that's actually
meted it's not like us in Singapore
where we pay 4990 we get unlimited at a
certain speed per month so in China
there are some internet connection that
is Meed and when you have a lot of
pixels within your diff elements they
think that you're wasting their
data and I mean as developers we know
this is funny but these guys are not
Engineers so they have this assumption
that you are wasting the data and they
don't use your site that
much so the question is how do you
customize your site for different
countries and uh what we created at
PayPal is this uh open source nodejs
Library called engine manga so engine
manga as of now it only supports the
JavaScript and the dust template engines
Alo is open source project so you can
contribute if you want more stuff on
it and what are some of the use cases of
this so can someone name me some of the
libraries you use for AB testing
anyone no one here does AB
testing what AB go anyone
else okay so how do you use Ab
go okay so like do you put it in a
configuration or do you put in a
controllers
or ah okay so you set it up to some data
store and based based on the output you
display in the controller you display
different stuff am I right okay so yeah
so one of the things we can do use
engine Monga for is AB testing and I'll
show you how to do that later there's
another way we can use engine manga for
which is to modify sections of the page
that should look different in different
countries uh so uh what we do is
basically we replace the partials with
the new view that's supposed to be
there and uh what about entire pages
that should look different in different
countries so engine manga allows you to
do it easily using configurations as
well
so you guys are all Engineers right no
sales guys here right so you'll go to
the code so to do some spe template
specialization stuff within engine mango
we just put this chunk of code into a
configuration file so in this scenario
uh the main template is is called
browsers so we change it to Chrome the
template we change the template name to
Chrome when so somehow within the users
uh uh flow within our website we realize
that this guy prefers Google so we
actually store it somewhere and then if
the preferred variable is Google we'll
change the template from browsers to
Chrome and the same for Firefox if we
realize the user prefers Mozilla or if
we think that the user is CH who sitting
somewhere there from Mozilla we'll
change it to Firefox and how we actually
set the context is we use this thing
called response. locals variable so we
will set response. locals. pref prefer
or we'll actually put the prefer key
inside a model object and when we render
it the response will call on the
middleware and then you'll replace the
templates
accordingly so yeah if the response.
local. prefer contains the value Mozilla
the partial browsers will be replaced by
Firefox it contains Mozilla you'll be
replaced by
Firefox and uh for this array right you
can actually put a whole bunch of
strings so if uh the value is anyone in
this array it'll repl by firo as well so
a quick demo of how to do it so I
actually hacked out a quick page just to
demonstrate this thing so I use an i
frame for this so if it's a generic page
you never do anything on a page you come
to this page we show you every single
type of browser there is assuming in a
parallel universe you actually can make
money making people download web
browsers so let's say we realize
somewhere through the users activity
that the user likes Mozilla or is
so uh I'm setting the cookies here so
from now on every time we access this
page we will get this page uh So based
on what has been already set in the
session key we display the right
things yeah and then if you want to show
the Chrome page you just so this is a
quick hack I did in the back end to
allow me to set a session
variables yeah so now that I said that
the user it prefers Google it just keep
showing up Chrome
and all these are done from the
configuration level I didn't do any
changes in the
controller so yeah so this is actually
all the code that's required to make
this happen so we set the session type
to so in my Set uh
specialization so in here right when I
passing this is actually the type so is
uh request. type it is Google I save in
the session and then when I launch the
page what I do is I create a new model
and I set the key prefer to the session
type and then when I render I pass in
the model and then it'll just swap out
the templates
accordingly so uh one of the key things
about this is that it can be done on
both the front end and back end style
things so you're not limited to where
you actually do all the template
specialization stuff so yeah at this
point did I lose
anyone no everyone is following okay
awesome
so next part of my talk which is
actually part of the stuff I'm actually
more interested in and better at
actually so performance so who here has
reached a point where you need to do
performance engineering like you need to
figure out how to scill your systems up
or you need to figure out how to
actually okay so what are some of the
ways you how how you do with performance
related issues test load load test so
then what you do after load
test Okay so find the things that slow
and makes them less slow okay anyone
else no so what you're doing is actually
vertical scaling
right yeah correct so what if you reach
a
point
huh ah okay fixing the bottom X in the
code okay so yeah there one way of doing
things so I mean we're talking as payal
but we actually do like a lot of other
Solutions out there world so let's just
talk about a few of them so one of the
solutions uh we find particularly
impressive is a cloud flare uh Cloud
flare actually provides a CDN it's free
for most for most users so you can just
put it as your DNS layer and they'll
handle all the CDN stuff for you uh it
is actually quite cool uh I did a couple
of benchmarks and it optimized my sight
loading times by around 50% and I have a
server in San Francisco I put it behind
CL
flat so that's one thing can do if you
don't have money to uh invest in a CDM
the other thing Cloud FL is actually
pretty awesome for is uh the security
team so they actually have a security
team to handle all a lot of security
issues uh especially all the SSL
vulnerabilities have been happening
recently so if you don't have an
in-house security team uh using Cloud
flam might actually be a really good
idea so who here have a security team in
house no one really
really yeah you should probably stick
with cl FL they'll protect
you and this other thing that I find
particularly useful and uh some of
PayPal projects actually run on this
like PayPal gs.com so New Relic is uh
performance tracking software uh I
benchmarked it on a couple of my own
personal applications a couple of times
and uh it adds a 10% performance
decrease to your applications because it
has to measure everything so there is
some performance Downs sets using New
Relic but if you're running a large pool
of apps you could just sample a few
applications to measure the performance
so that you know where exactly you need
to scale when the time
comes so uh yeah they help you track
your application performance
and you get alerts when the performance
starts to decline so it's actually very
configurable you can look at stuff from
all over the world like which countes
users are facing the worst performance
which countries users are facing better
performance
you can see which part of the stack is
causing the slowness and everything so
yeah and the thing is uh don't optimize
the wrong thing so who here has tried
optimizing and optimize the wrong thing
before I want to share the story about
that no one okay so I'll share a story
uh it's a story I heard somewhere is not
PayPal just to make it
clear so there was this MNC which is not
PayPal uh they so they found out that
their site was was loading it took 5
Seconds to load the site on an end
user's computer and they went they spent
$2 and5 million you know they said we
have to fix this problem we have to half
the time so they got around a team of 50
Engineers to sit down to figure out way
optimize the side they cut the time they
cut all the processing down by 50% so
they increased the application speed up
time by 50% so they went back and then
they deployed it they had a party and
then the next day users were still
complaining it was really slow so they
went back they look the users sto them
now and then when they went to Benchmark
on the users end it instead of taking 5
Seconds it took 4.9
seconds so finally they hired some
consultant the consultant actually told
them look he actually looked at all the
stuff and so what happened was the
network call took 4.8 seconds and the
application took 0.2 seconds so when
they optimize it by 50% they only reduce
application Time by 0.1 second the
network s still took 4.8 seconds so 4
4.8 plus 0.1 is still 4.9 so find out
where exactly the problem is before you
actually look into your scaling
Solutions and yeah uh New Relic provides
tools to help you do that and there are
actually a lot of different free stuff
out there that you can use leverage on
to run your toy apps or your startups uh
if anyone of you is interested can come
and talk to me after this uh I gave a
talk recently at a PHP meetup on how to
run how to deploy everything for free
and uh I have actually done circum
situations where I have 80 workers
running the car for free on Heroku so
there are ways to exploit all this stuff
so yeah as you can see from the New
Relic dashboard uh it actually breaks
down how much time it spent on each part
of the code so like here for example the
blue part is just the PHP stuff that's
running the green part is the request
que by Heroku and the orange by database
so like for this PL for example if it's
causing much loners I should take a look
at what the hell is happening and then
I'll scale it accordingly so yeah that's
it about performance from me and we have
come to the end of the talks from the
PayPal set of things we decided to make
it a bit shorter because I know there's
people out there and developers of be so
yeah any questions thanks thanks
Lawrence and Dexter thank
you questions I think they covered very
tangible tips from security it to
internationalization to AB
testing so um uh great speech about the
the CDN and stuff so about that what
about like uh having your own varish
cash in front or your own Cash System
instead of like going to crop there so
the thing is that if you have your own
varish cash in front right uh you
actually have to deploy servers all over
the world to make use of that fully
because one of the main bottom RS is not
your web server passing out stuff slowly
the main problem is the network so yeah
if you have if you use a CDN you have
all over the world it is nearer to the
users it reduces a
time um sorry another question so how
would you debar the issues you have uh
from the CDN to your end so that is an
art there's no one way to do it and uh
at PayPal we actually do face that issue
sometimes so what we normally do is that
we just Purge the entire
cash and that often like it often solves
all problems yeah cool any other last
question I have used a cloud flare uh
earlier so I found some issues with
Cloud flare because when the system goes
down CL are still routing the traffic to
the same uh down the box so is it still
happening right now because still we are
talking about Cloud flare because we get
rid of the cloud FL and we went to I so
do you think he still having that issue
so from PayPal perspective PayPal
doesn't use cloud flag because we have
servers all over the world to ensure up
time this is from my own personal
perspective so the way I look at it is
very simple right I'm a single developer
I don't have an infrastructure tip so I
Outsource it to clout Flair and they are
professionals so even if they have
downtime they normally has less downtime
than what I get yeah because we found
that isue because we had one day one
some time we had a down time for one
hour but the club was still routing the
traffic from the user one hour
continuously to the wherever the Box
gone down we are getting the traffic to
that box so yeah that's a danger of
using CL FL gu I uh you have mentioned
that there is a efficient caching so the
caching is not optimized for the uh shut
down to box or uh it's not running the
kill the box so you can there's API for
to actually purch the cash and
everything so you might want to take a
look at that as well yeah maybe I can
try it again yeah okay
thanks cool any other
questions uh what sort of profiling
tools do you use do you like uh depend
on the external monitoring tools like
New Relic or uh just fire up some tools
and see where the of time is going okay
so within PayPal we actually use naos
because uh we can't use a third party
thing to look code because of BCI
compliance issues but uh for if you are
just a startup just starting to start a
new Relic is a good place to start
because you just install and it's done
you get to see all the PD graphs and
everything it's really clear where the
bottom NE is you don't have to dig much
into data and they if I remember
correctly they even have like uh tips on
how you can optimize which section of
the code you should be optimizing if you
are talking about databases and stuff A
New Relic provides a lot of plugins for
the different databases that you can use
uh if you're using mongod DB there
Management Service that you can try as
well that actually tracks like which
query is the most most expensive queries
and which and what index you should be
optimizing in order for those queries to
run
faster yeah so it depends on your
specific use
case